in this demo we'll show you how to
migrate a two-tier lamp stack
application with my great for anthis
let's start with our VMware vSphere
setup on premises there are two VMware
VMs in this application one for the
application server and one for the
database server this CRM application is
the application that we are going to be
migrating right now the application is
running on premises now we'll go to
Google cloud platform Google kubernetes
engine cluster the database server has
already been migrated and a load
balancer is already configured for the
application let's deploy migrate four
anthos into the cluster after that's
complete let's add the VMware setup as a
source for migration access to the
remote setup is facilitated by a migrate
for compute engine deployment the setup
is now complete let's create a migration
to generate the migration plan y amyl
now we can review the migration plan y
amal in cloud shell it's important to
exclude certain types of files and
directories from the migration now that
we've reviewed the migration plan we can
start the artifact generation process
for the application server this includes
a container image a docker file and a
reference deployment yamo here in cloud
shell we can also examine the migration
status of the application now we'll
return to our VMware vSphere web client
a snapshot is automatically taken on the
VMware side this is to process the
migration without disruption to the
running workload we can return to cloud
shell and see when the migration is
complete now we'll return to the Google
container registry and refresh the
images when we look inside the
application folder we can see the
captured container image is now ready in
the Google container registry
when we refresh the bucket in Google
container storage we can look inside and
see that the container artifacts are
stored in GCS now we'll go back to cloud
shell to download the artifacts and
review the deployment yamo after
inspecting the deployment y amyl we will
apply the deployment to kubernetes to
test the workload we'll go back to the
google kubernetes engine cluster to look
at the application deployment details
when we refresh the application we can
see that all three of the managed pods
within this application are now running
in a cluster in google kubernetes engine
finally we'll go back to our application
which is no longer running on-premises
but is now running in containers in
google kubernetes engine on Google cloud
platform
[Music]